Okay, we are on time now, so thank you very much for coming.
This is very late in the day, and I am the only thing between you and dinner,
so I'm trying to keep it entertaining.
And
there is a QR code that was shown where people can
ask questions by message or the app.
Okay, so
the first thing I wanted to disclose is that I don't consider myself an
expert. So the expert session may not be the best
title, but I'm basically communicating what I learned from people in the
lab and collaborators, and I'll try to bring that up during the
presentation. And the topic is basically trying to
exploit defective tumor immune cell interactions, and I
hope I convince you that there is a whole environment
here that can be modulated. And these are my disclosures.
So arguably, the most relevant interaction between cancer cells and
immune cells is the HLA-TCR interaction.
And this is shown here. You can see here this is the invariant chain and the
variant chain. And then basically what happens is that peptides,
usually short nine amino acid long peptides, are presented from the cancer
cell recognized by the TCR, and this basically is the
foundation of adaptive immune response where T cells can
do their job. And for many, many
years it's been established that this pathway can be defective
in cancer. I think a prototype of that is the
downregulation of beta-2 microglobulin, which is this invariant chain, which is
necessary to stabilize peptides.
And this is a paper we published many years ago now where we found that in patients
with acquired resistance to checkpoint blockade, in this case dual checkpoint
blockade, we could see a biallelic loss of the beta-2m
locus. This is chromosome 15, and this is the baseline biopsy.
You can see nothing going on in acquired resistant lesion, that there was
a biallelic loss of beta-2 microglobulin.
We confirmed that using protein analysis, and you can see here the cancer cells are
green, and the cancer cell lost beta-2 microglobulin,
consistent with the lack of the gene.
And then Katie Politi in our institution modeled that in mice, and we could see
that just removal of beta-2m from the cancer cell was sufficient to
confer resistance to PD-1 inhibitors in a carcinogen-induced mouse
model. So we have very strong evidence that beta-2m
downregulation can happen in human tumors, and it can mediate
resistance to immunotherapy.
But I think that the most important concept here is that the antigen presentation
pathway is much bigger than just beta-2 microglobulin. It's quite complex.
And what I'm showing here, the HLA class one pathway referred to as APM for
antigen presentation machinery, is actually a sequential
set of steps where antigens are generally generated at the
immunoproteasome by these three proteins, PSMB 8, 9 and 10.
And then those peptides, once they're generated, they're processed by peptidases,
usually amino peptidases. And then from the cytosol, were
generally degraded very quickly.
They are internalized into the endoplasmic reticulum
via the TAP transporter, which is formed by these two proteins, TAP 1 and
TAP 2. And then after the peptides have been loaded onto the
ER, they're loaded onto the HLA by this protein loading
complex formed by tapasin, calreticulin, calnexin, ERP57.
And then after that, they're conjugated with beta-2m and then transferred to the
membrane. So the point I want to make is that this pathway is complex, and
things can go wrong beyond beta-2 microglobulin, and I will
show you some examples of that. Now, at least in theory, in
the absence of a proficient antigen presentation, T cells will not be
able to recognize cancer cells, and this could obviously be a
problem.
So in the first part of this presentation, I will focus on work done in my
lab, where we have looked at the entire pathway.
We have been dissecting out alterations in the whole pathway.
But today we will focus on TAP 1 and TAP 2 and how the
downregulation of these proteins can affect cancer cell
recognition by T cells.
As an introduction, this TAP transporter is a
heterodimeric transporter formed by TAP 1 and TAP 2, and this is a
cartoon showing the expected structure.
There is an ATP binding domain in the internal part of the ER and
a pore-forming domain. And this is basically where the peptides generated by the
proteasome are shuttled into the ER to be loaded onto the HLA.
At least conceptually, the current notion is that these
proteins are equally represented, and they're expressed in most nucleated
cells. Without this, there shouldn't be a
proper presentation of antigens.
So the first thing we did to query this, we validated assays to look at
this reliably. And this is an example of a human lung cancer.
And what you're seeing in green are the cancer cells.
What you're seeing in blue are the non-cancer cells, what we call stroma or
non-tumor cells, from the same case.
And then TAP 1 is shown in red, TAP 2 is shown in yellow, and CD8 T cells
are shown in white. And one thing that stands out, particularly from
this case, is that if you see the cancer cells, again, shown here in green, they
lack expression of TAP 2, while the non-cancer cells, they
express normal levels. And this is what we call cancer cell selective
downregulation. You can see that TAP 1 is not downregulated in the
cancer cell. Now, there are a few other things to note, for example, that the
only cells that are positive in the cancer cell region are actually CD8 T cells,
but there are very few CD8 T cells in this tumor.
And I'll go back to that, because this absence of T cells is
not fundamentally explained by a lack of antigen.
Suggests that there is something else going on, and I will come back.
So now when we look at this at scale, we screened
819 tumors. These are all treatment-naive tumors, so
even before seeing any treatment, including
immunotherapy.And what we can see is that
24% of these treatment-naive tumors have
downregulation of TAP2, which basically means that they have lower TAP2
in the cancer cells than the non-cancer cells of the same specimen.
But only 6% have downregulation of TAP1, and this was already
interesting. We see this sort of asymmetric behavior where TAP2 is
most commonly downregulated. But then another 18%
had actually downregulation of both TAP1 and TAP2.
And these are large numbers when you think that about half of treatment-naive lung
cancers have an issue with TAP1, TAP2, or both.
Now, what we see at the impact of this, again, these are baseline specimens
from patients that went on to get treatment, we could see that those tumors with
low TAP2, those patients did worse after treatment with
immunotherapy.
And this was quite consistent with a hazard ratio of 1.8, so
80% more risk of dying when they were treated
with low TAP2. So we know this is clinically meaningful,
and it has consequences for the patient outcome.
We did not see that with the downregulation of TAP1 or in patients that
were treated with chemotherapy, so this seems to be
immunotherapy specific.
But then the main question came, okay, what's going on?
Is this the obvious mechanism in which downregulation of
TAP2 will be translating into fewer antigens? And we wanted to prove that.
So the first thing we did was downregulating TAP1, TAP2, or both
artificially in lung cancer cells.
We tried KRAS and EGFR mutant lung cancer
cells. We downregulated TAP1 or TAP2, and I
will point you here to this figure.
This is in the control condition or after treatment with cytokines.
And if you see, the ones treated with interferon gamma TNF alpha,
then we co-cultured these cancer cells with tumor
antigen-specific T cells. So basically, these are CD8 T cells that express
a TCR that recognize a cancer cell antigen that we know is
expressed in the cancer cell, so again, tumor antigen-specific.
We could see that when we downregulate TAP1, there was a significant
reduction in T cell killing. When we removed TAP2, it
was more pronounced, and when we removed TAP1 and TAP2, it was
very similar to TAP2 alone. So this suggests that TAP2 has a dominant
effect in protecting cancer cells from tumor
antigen-specific killing.
Then to show this more convincingly, we actually knock out
TAP2, so this is different. The prior one was a small interference RNA, so knock
down. This is knock out. We can see basically the same.
You can see here again, when we remove TAP2 now totally, there
was a significant reduction in the T cell killing.
And then we knocked back in TAP2. We reintroduced TAP2,
and we recovered the effect. So this clearly segregates with TAP2
and points out its prominent effect in cancer cell protection.
But then the question was, is this all mediated by antigen?
And the reason why we brought up this question is because we saw
things, as I showed you, that were not explained by reduced antigen.
So to answer that question, we collaborated with a colleague, Etienne Caron at
Yale, and we did immunopeptidomes.
So basically, we take these lung cancer cells,
with or without TAP2 expression, and then we do
immunoprecipitation with a pan-HLA antibody.
This is a very famous clone used by a lot of people, and then we pull it down
and do mass spec. So now we can see changes in the entire
repertoire of peptides that are loaded onto the HLA, in this case,
HLA-A, B, and C.
And what we could find was actually very interesting.
Here we're seeing the wild type TAP2, and here the knockouts.
And there was no change in the range of the size of the peptides.
As expected, it peaked at nine amino acids with a range between about eight and
12, very similar in the knockout. And then we saw about 10%
to 15% reduction in the total amount of peptides loaded.
And this was quite shocking, because what we expected was no antigens,
because they were not pushed into the ER.
And we actually saw a relatively mild reduction in the antigens.
So this certainly did not explain the protection of the cancer
cells by tumor antigen-specific killing assays.
So then we said, okay, maybe there are other functions that are independent
from the antigen. And this, I think, is the most interesting part because none of
this has been looked at before. And I think I will try to
convince you that these are actually arguably more important than the
antigen-independent functions.
So the first thing we did to look at this was knocking down
TAP2 in lung cancer cells and do targeted transcriptomics.
And one thing that came out that was quite impressive is that when we were
just downregulating TAP2, we got downregulation of a number of relevant
molecules, including TAP1, immunoproteasome components, chemokines, and
cytokines. So just downregulation of TAP2 in the cancer cells
produces and rewires the transcriptome of the cell.
But then we found prominent upregulation of SOX1, which you can see here,
that it's a very prominent and well-established inhibitor of interferon gamma
signaling. SOX1 actually binds directly to JAK, which is downstream of the
interferon gamma receptor.
To validate this at the protein level, we again knocked down TAP2,
and we could see increase in SOX1 by flow cytometry, so this is now
protein. But this was actually bidirectional.
We then transfected a flag TAP2,
you can see here. When we overexpressed TAP2, SOX1 went down.
So there is this bidirectional interaction between TAP2 and SOX1.
Then we wanted to validate this in human tissue, so we took primary human tumors.
We dissociated them, sorted the cancer cells, and we did
RNA sequencing and ATAC sequencing.
And what we found is exactly what I showed you in the cell lines.
You can see here in the
cancer relative to normal tissue, we saw downregulation of that TAP2 transcript,
then upregulation of SOX1. So we have pretty good evidence that this
mechanism is in place in human tumors, and it's not just a cell
line artifact.Now,
another interesting finding, and I think I told you that it was
surprising that the tumors with low TAP2 had very few T cells that actually
infiltrated the cancer cell nest.
So we looked at the entire transcriptome of cells with and without TAP2
knockout, and you can see that among transcripts that were
upregulated was SOX1. So we confirmed this
upregulation of this interferon gamma inhibitor.
But then we found downregulation of a number of key chemokines that are critical
for T-cell chemotraction, and we quantify a few of them.
Below here you can see CXCL9 was non-significantly lower in the knockout,
but CXCL10, CCL5, and CXCL11 were very
low in the knockout. So what this supports is that the reduction of
TAP2 can actually reduce the capacity of cancer cells to attract T
cells, and that could explain that sort of immune exclusion
phenotype.
Interestingly, we did not see changes in the two interferon gamma receptors, so
this is not just mediated by reduced expression of the
receptors and most likely attributed to SOX1 upregulation.
But then, because we saw this SOX1 effect, we decided to
treat the cells with cytokines and see if the response to cytokines was
different in cells with or without TAP2.
And what you're seeing here are cells in the control knockdown or
scrambled and in the TAP2 knockdown, we treat it with interferon
gamma, and we look at the transcriptome.
And what you can see that in the control condition, a number of interferon
gamma-sensitive genes were upregulated.
You can see IDO1, JAK, PD-L1, and so on.
But in the knockdown, we could not see that.
So clearly, the TAP2-deficient cells are less sensitive to
interferon gamma, and a very similar response was seen when we treated with
interferon gamma TNF alpha.
Now, to validate this at the protein level, we took again lung cancer
cells with or without a TAP2 knockout now, so not
knockdown, but knockout. And you could see that upon treatment with interferon
gamma, the amount of phosphorylated STAT1 was
lower in the knockout. And then when we reintroduce
TAP2, we recover the signaling of phospho-STAT1,
which is known to be downstream of interferon gamma.
And a very similar result was seen with IRF1.
So collectively, this demonstrates that just downregulation of TAP2
prevents the signaling of interferon gamma and TNF alpha, and
makes cells resistant to interferon gamma and pro-inflammatory cytokines.
We expanded this a little bit more.
We did a phosphoprotein array with 37 signaling markers, and you can see that
it's not only phosphorylated STAT1, there is downregulation of
phosphorylated PLC gamma 1 and upregulation of phospho-STAT2.
So basically, just manipulating TAP2 changes completely
the inflammatory wiring of the cell, both transcriptionally but also in
the signaling.
Now, one fundamental question is how is TAP2 being downregulated
in lung cancer cells? And generally, in cancer, we think about
mutations, deletions, and genetic problems.
So the first thing we did, we look at the TCGA lung cancer data set, which
is about 875 lung adenocarcinomas and squamous
carcinomas. And we look at deleterious mutations in TAP2 gene,
basically meaning
nonsense mutations or biallelic losses and things that would really
compromise the structure of the gene.
And we could find only about 1% of cases that had deleterious
TAP2 mutations. So clearly, downregulation of TAP2
is not a consequence of a genetic alteration in the vast majority of cases.
So we hypothesized that this could have been an epigenetic effect.
So we ran primary tumors using ATAC-seq, and we
compared the lung cancer with adjacent non-tumor tissue, which is
indicated as NAT. And what we could see, and is shown here, is that in
the cancer, the promoter region of TAP2, which is three kilobases above
and below the ATG, the start codon, was significantly
reduced. So basically, the accessibility of the chromatin is shut down,
and TAP2 is likely being less transcribed.
And we'll identify a couple of motifs of transcription factors that are
binding that region that could actually explain why TAP2 is being
silenced epigenetically in human tumors.
Then the question was how is this happening? Who is mediating this?
And after a number of experiments, we identified that tumors, human
tumors with low TAP2, generally had more interleukin-4
on bulk transcriptome analysis. So we hypothesized that interleukin-4 could
do this. So we treat both KRAS and EGFR
mutant lung cancer cells with recombinant human IL4, and we could
actually rapidly reduce TAP2. You can see that within 12 hours,
we could see significant reduction in the levels of TAP2 protein, which
demonstrates that IL4 is sufficient to downregulate TAP2 in cancer cells.
Now, not surprisingly, the effect of IL4 was
epigenetically. You can see here that we could reduce the chromatin
accessibility in the TAP2 promoter, just adding IL4, and it was
only partially restored when we co-treated with interferon gamma and TNF alpha.
And this is important because there has been this notion in the field that antigen
presentation is not a big problem because it can be corrected with interferon gamma
or some inflammatory stimuli. But we actually don't see that.
You can see, for example, here, when we treat with cells with IL4, we see a
reduction in TAP2. We add cytokines, and we don't
restore the level to a normal situation.
So basically,
just adding inflammation or inflammatory cytokines doesn't restore the
problem.
Not surprisingly, you can see here that SOX1 was upregulated by
IL4, which is consistent with the data we have seen in tumors and
cells.To
confirm that, we actually went back and looked at the human tumors.
We look at the IL4 RNA because the cytokine can be
secreted and that's problematic for detection, but the RNA is not.
So we actually look at tumors, and this is an example of a cancer.
You can see the cancer cells are in green.
They lack TAP2 expression, but TAP2 is fine in the non-cancer cells.
And you can see a lot of IL4 RNA, mostly colocalizing with
CD11b. So these are most likely myeloid-derived suppressor
cells that are interspersed the cancer cells.
They're producing IL4 locally, and that could mediate the
suppression in TAP2 that I just showed you using in vitro experiments.
Now, the big question is can we do something about it?
And this is important, because
the fact that the genes are fine and that this is epigenetic opens
the possibility to actually restore expression of TAP2.
So to answer that question, the first idea was to block IL4
signaling, and fortunately, interleukin-4 has only one receptor, so we can
effectively target that receptor using antibodies.
So we took primary human tumors, we desegregated them into single-cell
suspensions, and then we separated cancer cells and T cells in an
autologous fashion. So these are fully matched by all HLAs
and they're fully human.
And then we co-cultured them with or without treatment with an IL4
blocking antibody, plus minus pembrolizumab, which is an anti-PD-1.
And then we measure CD8 T cell activation using CD25, and then we
look at autologous T cell killing using annexin V expression
of EpCAM positive malignant cells.
And what you can see is that when we added both the blocker of IL4
and pembrolizumab, we could significantly increase the activation of CD8
T cells.
And then we could also enhance the cancer cell killing ability, which
demonstrates that just blocking the IL4 receptor can enhance the
activity of checkpoint blockade.
Now, in parallel, when we were working on this, there was a paper by Miriam Merad's
group showing in a clinical trial that blocking the IL4 receptor
using a commercial
drug that it's currently approved for asthma was actually beneficial for patients
with lung cancer refractory to checkpoint blockade.
So we believe that this is actually already translated clinically
from another group.
But then the question was, can we do something else?
And I just showed you that this is an epigenetic mechanism, so we
thought that there could be ways that we could use repurposed
drugs, mostly epigenetic modulators, to re-express TAP2 in the
cancer cells and bypass the IL4 effect.
So to answer that question, we did a drug screen where we set up
an assay to look at cancer cells, lung cancer cells.
We treated them with about 3,000 compounds, many of which are FDA
approved and some epigenetic modulators.
And then we look for upregulation of TAP2 and
upregulation of PD-L1. And what we were focusing on are
drugs that could upregulate TAP2 without upregulating PD-L1.
And this is relevant because both PD-L1 and TAP2 are sensitive to interferon gamma,
so we didn't want to upregulate both.
And as you can see here in the red dots, we found a number of compounds
that could upregulate TAP2 without modifying PD-L1.
So basically, we were trying to harness the pro-inflammatory effect without the
immunosuppressive effect.
A summary of the compounds that we identify is shown here on the bottom left,
and surprisingly, we found agents that are already used in anti-cancer
treatment in lung cancer. You can see dasatinib is a tyrosine kinase inhibitors
approved for lung cancer. But then a number of taxanes, actually three
taxanes, docetaxel,
and a few others came out in the screen.
Now, taxanes are used usually in the second line and above in lung cancer
patients, and they're known to be inflammatory, but nobody knows why.
Because they're supposed to do microtubule disaggregation.
So we believe there's a big component here that could explain why taxanes
are so inflammatory. But then interestingly, you can see here we found a
number of HDAC inhibitors. These are three, two of
which are already approved. SAHA is vorinostat, is approved for heme
malignancies. And you can see that there were two pan-HDAC
inhibitors and one HDAC6 inhibitor.
So that we then treated the cells with some of these compounds.
This is an example of vorinostat or SAHA.
You can see that we could increase TAP2 expression, increase antigens in the
surface, and increase the tumor antigen-specific killing.
So just adding, in this case, SAHA, could restore
the functionality and the tumor antigen-specific killing.
So we believe there are good avenues here to use repurposed drugs to
be able to treat patients that have defective TAP2
expression.
So in summary from this part, what I hope I convince you
of is that there is this non-antigen dependent effect
of TAP2 downregulation. I actually kind of minimized the
antigen part, which we do see about 20% reduction in the antigens.
But we found this interesting intercellular axis where
myeloid-derived suppressor cells that are CD11b positive within
the cancer produce IL4 that signals via IL4
receptor and produces at least two effects.
One, which is silencing epigenetically TAP2, which
increases SOX1 and shuts down interferon gamma signaling, and then
also there is a reduction in chemokines and pro-inflammatory signals that makes
these tumors more immune-evasive.
And I think the most important thing is that this can be targeted.
Now, one other question we ask, and this is unpublished, is
does this mechanism project during cancer progression?
So to answer that question, we collected primary human lung cancers in
a cohort of lung cancer brain metastases, and we just wanted to compare the
levels, in this case, of beta-2 microglobulin and phosphorylated
STAT1 or IRF1. Examples of the staining is shown
here. And I won't go into too much detail because of
time.We measured two independent cohorts, and what was really
fascinating is that in both cohorts, we could see that lung cancer brain
metastases, which are shown as LBM, consistently had lower
beta-2 microglobulin than the primary tumors.
But this was not true in the extracranial metastases.
So only the brain metastases had downregulation of beta-2m,
while phosphorylated STAT1 and IRF1 were comparable.
So this basically is a different mechanism, where now interferon gamma
signaling is preserved, but the brain mets had even lower antigen
presentation proteins than the primaries.
And this was quite consistent in the second cohort.
You can see here again the lung brain metastasis, lower beta-2m, no
difference with the extracranial metastasis, and comparable levels of interferon
gamma signaling. So now we're trying to understand if this is a
consequence of the brain metastases, or it could actually be the cause of
brain metastases and try to intervene in that process.
And we have a manuscript under revision where we actually are looking at the
mechanisms, but I will not go into that.
Now when we compared the subset of patients that had paired samples, so these
are primary and brain metastases from the same patient
longitudinally, we can see again a significant downregulation of
beta-2m in the cancer cells, but also in the stromal cells.
And this is really interesting because it seems to be a field effect, like both the
cancer cells and the neighboring non-cancer cells have lower antigen
presentation. No significant difference in interferon gamma signaling,
supporting that this is an independent mechanism.
We also look at TAP1 and TAP2, and a long story short, we do not
see differences in TAP1 between primary lung, brain, and
extracranial metastases. And we see a slight reduction of
TAP2, which is the boundary of significance, it's actually
significant in the stromal cells, but not in the cancer cells.
But now we don't see a difference between the lung brain metastases and the
extracranial. So it seems like metastatic cells in the
brain down-regulate beta-2 microglobulin, but not in
the extracranial metastases. But now all the metastases
down-regulate TAP2. So this is really
getting very granular, and I think we will need to study more to try to
perturb those systems.
Now, what about other tumor types? Again, this is also unpublished.
We look at this in colorectal cancer, and this is data you can see here.
This is what we call an uneventful or normal tumor, if you
want, which TAP1 and TAP2 are expressed everywhere,
unaltered TAP1 and TAP2. You can see the cancer cells express it, the
non-cancer cells, and this is a case in colorectal cancer where the cancer
cells lost TAP1 and TAP2. You can see that normal cells are fine,
but the cancer cells don't express it.
Now when we look at this again at scale, we look at a little over 400 tumors.
We see that 16% of colorectal cancers lose TAP2,
10% TAP1, and 30% lose both. So it's similar to lung, but
not the same. And this adds another layer of complexity, which is that
different tumor types may have different
dominant mechanisms of immunivation, and I think we should think carefully
about their significance in that context.
Certainly not only lung.
So in conclusion from the first part, I hope I convinced you that immunivation in
lung cancer involves complex TME interactions between cancer and
non-malignant cells. Here we found this axis between myeloid cells, cancer
cells, and T cells.
TAP2 loss or downregulation is frequent in lung cancer, mediates
immunivation resistance to immunotherapy, and there is a possible role in
colorectal cancer and brain metastases, both of which could also be harnessed
therapeutically.
Three, that the mechanisms of immunivation in lung cancer associated with TAP2
loss include antigen-independent effects, and I believe that these actually
are more relevant than the antigen-dependent effects, which I think that we
generally associate with this biology.
And finally, the TAP2 downregulation in lung cancer is epigenetically in
nature,
and the most important thing, that it's reversible, so there's something we can do
about it, either blocking IL-4 signaling or using epigenetic
modulators. And now we're planning a clinical trial where we're selecting patients
based on low TAP2, and we're planning interventions that include
taxanes and epigenetic modulators to validate this further
and try to exploit it.
So now in the second part of the lecture, I'll talk about another really
interesting tumor immune cell interaction, which is something that has been known
in the field as immune exclusion. And what I mean by that is
shown here in the slide, where you can see that the majority of T cells and B cells
are in the stroma, yet they don't enter very well the
cancer cell nest. Again, it's shown in green cytokeratin.
You can see that most of the CD8s, which are red, are in the stroma, and
very few are actually able to enter.
And this is on a quantitative level, it's actually pretty prominent.
You can see that we find five times more CD4s and CD8 in the
stroma than in the cancer cell nest.
And this is problematic because I just showed you that to recognize the
cancer cell, the T cells need to enter in contact.
They need to see the TCR antigen interaction.
So to do that, they need to be in touch.
But then after the recognition, to kill, they need to exert their
mechanisms of cytotoxicity, which are perforin granzyme system,
cytokines such as interferon or TNF alpha, or death receptors such
as Fas. All of these mechanisms require proximity.
So the main question is, if we have these lymphocytes in the stroma, how are
they recognizing TCR antigens, and how are they executing the
killing? This really doesn't make any sense.
So the problem, I think, in the field is that we pathologists, and
generally we kind of accepted that.
I don't think it's news for everyone here that, oh, yeah, the majority of immune
cells are in the stroma. But we haven't done anything about it, and it's
actually been relatively difficult.
So many years ago, we started thinking about it,
and we elaborated a little bit more on this idea that has been...
pointed before and was recently reviewed by us.
And Miguel, who is a very talented postdoc who is sitting in the audience, spent
time here with other colleagues writing this.
We actually look at the evidence of these phenotypes.
And the traditional
view is that there are tumors that are infiltrated, so they have CD8 T
cells in the cancer cell nest. There are excluded
tumors in which the CD8s are in the boundary or the periphery,
but they cannot enter, and then immune desert tumors, which basically have no
T cells.
And these are examples of those patterns.
You can see here
one, two, and three representing this cartoon.
Now, what is the problem is that when we actually look at real human tumors, and
you're seeing one here on the right, we can find the three patterns in the same
tumor. And this is very common. So when we do eyeballing basically,
or estimation, we're very likely to not know what to do.
Because if we look at this region, we find one pattern, if we look at this region,
we find another pattern, and so on.
So we really didn't have the right tools to ask questions
about immune exclusion.
So to address that question, again, Miguel spent some time looking at this, and we
basically quantified the cells in the cancer cell nest and in the
stroma. And with a very simple ratio of density of the
cells in the tumor, in the stroma associated with k-means clustering, we
actually found patterns that are consistent, measurable, and reproducible,
where we can see a subset of tumors where the majority of areas are
excluded, which are shown here as zero ratio.
So most of the
lymphocytes are within the cancer cell nest.
Then we found another group where the majority of lymphocytes were in areas of the
tumor that were infiltrated, so they were in the cancer cell nest.
And then we found the tumors that had both exclusion, shown here again
as zero, and infiltration, shown here.
But these three patterns were consistent and were selected in an
unsupervised fashion. So it was the algorithm and not our cells
deciding what is what. And then we look at the
survival of those tumors measured at baseline after
immunotherapy.
And what you can see that altogether we found that about 20% of tumors have this
immune excluded-like phenotype.
So basically again, the majority of fields of view have exclusion.
About 20% were what we called infiltrated-like or dominated by
cancer cell infiltration, and then about 60% were all over the place.
But the interesting thing is that when we look at the survival after immunotherapy,
only the ones showing this immune excluded-like phenotype did actually worse.
And this is collapsed here on the right where we actually think this
meaningful. So basically those tumors with more exclusion do worse after
immunotherapy, supporting that this is a relevant
spatial orientation.
But then the question, and so far, I think the dominating paradigm has
been that exclusion is a passive phenomenon.
What I mean by that is that we have always thought that excluded tumors
lack something. They lack antigen, they lack dendritic cells,
something is missing.
But we challenge that hypothesis with the idea that maybe this is an active
phenomenon. Maybe cancer cells can produce something that will
slow down or keep T cells away. And this is work done in
collaboration with Liping Chen lab, and Jason Zhang spent a number of
years actually
generating this migration assay where he took a
modified Boyden chamber and add CXCL11 on
one side to induce migration and transfected a number of soluble
factors into cancer cells to find molecules that
which could be expressed in the cancer cell and would slow down T cell
migration.
In a long story short, you can see here one such molecule called
PLA2G10. This is a group 10 phospholipase that, as shown
here, upon treatment, the lymphocytes slowed down.
There was fewer migration induced by CXCL11, CXCL19,
and a number of other molecules, and blockade of that PLA2G10
actually reduce or restore the migration of the lymphocyte.
So this is the concept of what we're now calling T cell excluders, which are
molecules that the cancer cell can produce that will slow down or
stop T cells and could explain this immune exclusion
phenotype.
Now, to prove this experimentally, we generated a mouse model where we
overexpress this PLA2G10. This is KPC pancreatic, and we also
did MC38. And you can see that overexpression of
PLA2G10 enhanced the cancer
growth,
and also reduced the number of T cells, and it was synergistic with
anti-PD-1. This is 1C11, is an antibody that blocks the catalytic domain of
PLA2G10. So there was a good rationale in vivo that
blocking PLA2G10 could enhance tumor rejection and T
cell infiltration.
But then we also want to confirm that in human tumors, and this is
TCGA data, we could see upregulation of this PLA2G10 in lung cancer
relative to normal lung. And then we generate an assay, and we could actually
find lung cancer cells shown here in green that express
PLA2G10. And this is really interesting because I just told you that
PLA2G10 is a secreted phospholipase.
So somehow the cancer cells are producing or retaining
PLA2G10 locally to mediate the
effect on T cells. And as shown here, tumors with very
high PLA2G10 in the cancer cells generally had fewer
infiltration, particularly of CD8 T cells.
So we have pretty good evidence that this idea of T cell
exclusion, active T cell exclusion, works both experimentally but
in human tumors too.
So then finally, we wanted to look at this from another side.
And we basically thought that we may be able to discover more of these T cell
excluders by now looking at tissue.
So what we did here, we collected 250 primary lung cancers.
We analyzed them with a panel, as I just showed you before, and then we
used the formula that we created to identify T cell
exclusion.We took this cohort of 250 tumors, and we went
to the top 20% more excluded and 20% more
infiltrated. And we analyzed them, as shown here, using our
algorithm, and this is an example of an excluded tumor.
You can see that the immune cells are in the stroma. This is important.
There are immune cells, they're just in the wrong place.
And then this is an immune-infiltrated tumor, where you can see that the majority
of cells can actually enter the cancer cell nest.
So this is just an example of what we did.
But then we analyzed them using spatial transcriptomics to try to focus on
molecules that were upregulated in the cancer cell or immune-excluded or
immune-infiltrated.
And what you're seeing here is the result from that experiment.
On the right are transcripts that are enriching the cancer cells of
immune-infiltrated tumors. Not surprisingly, we found chemokines,
CXCL9, CXCL11, a few others, TAP1,
TAP2, which was very rewarding to see that.
But on the molecules enriching immune-excluded tumors, we actually
rediscovered PLEC2G10, which you can see there, but also
HER2, AXIN2, which was previously reported.
So this actually made a lot of sense.
Now, the most exciting thing is that we found all of these molecules or
transcripts that have not been associated with immune exclusion or T
cell migration that are enriched in immune-excluded tumors.
And now I think we have a number of candidates that we can start looking at to
potentially target even more immune excluders.
So I'll show you two examples. This is called TCE1 and TCE3, both of which are
secreted factors. We're prioritizing secreted factors.
So we look at the literature, and T cell excluder one, you can see here, this is
TCGA data, is mostly upregulated in lung squamous
carcinoma, not so much in adenocarcinoma.
It's negatively correlated with T cells in general and associated with worse
outcomes, so pretty good so far.
When we look across different tumor types, and lung is highlighted here with the
bar, it's prominently upregulated in lung cancer, mostly, as
I said, in squamous, but also in glioblastoma and also
uterine carcinosarcoma and so on.
So it could be that this mechanism, it's prominent in more than one
tumor type and could potentially generalize.
This is an example, the second example, to T cell excluder number three.
You can see now this is high in adenocarcinoma, not so much in squamous, so it
could be that different histologies are actually picking a different excluder
mechanism. It's also negatively correlated with T cells and
also somewhat associated with worse outcome.
But now when we look at across different tumor types, we again see massive
upregulation in lung adenocarcinoma relative to normal lung.
And you can see again, colorectal cancer, very high relative to
normal, pancreatic cancer, and others.
So it could be that some of these excluders could affect other tumor types and
not only lung. And now we're trying to figure out how it works.
Now, to validate some of these excluders, because what I just showed you is just a
correlation, we went back to a Boyden chamber assay of migration.
So we basically took, again, the migration assay.
We put CXCL11 on one side, we put the lymphocytes on the other
side, and then we look at migration with or without treatment with this
T cell excluder, candidate T cell excluders, and then we measure the cells by
flow.
And a long story short, you can see here in migration experiments that T cell
excluder one and three significantly reduced the migration, and this is shown here.
What was notorious, they did not change the expression of CXCR3,
which is the main receptor for CXCL11, so it's not down-regulating
the receptor, and it did not affect the viability of T cells, so we
believe that this is a problem with migration.
And now we're trying to find out the mechanism of that.
So finally, I think a
problem we face is how do we move this forward?
Do we have the right models to ask questions about spatial orientation?
If we do single-cell experiments, we cannot ask spatial questions, and in mice,
it's very hard. So we had to create a model in which we could ask
these questions. And to address this, we created these TAPEs,
which stands for Tumor-Associated Primary Explants, where we actually take
primary human tumors. We can grow them in a little dome of extracellular matrix
and keep them alive for up to about 10 days, which is good enough to do
pharmacodynamic analysis. These are pictures, and we generally also take
non-tumor tissue. So we can actually keep the tissue intact, we
can treat it with different things, and then ask questions about spatial
distribution using the same assays that I just showed you.
This is an example of the model where you can see in this case, it's a positive
control. We treat it or not with interleukin-2, which is expected to
increase CD4 and CD8 T cell proliferation.
And these are different days, so day zero, three, five, up to seven.
And you can see that we can detect
expansion of CD4s and CD8s, and we can resolve them, the tumor and stroma.
This is all done using FFPE preparation from these specimens.
And we have tested a number of drugs at this point in the lab, bispecific
antibodies, antibody-drug conjugates, immunomodulatory drugs, and I think we've got
a good idea of how to interrogate the model.
The most interesting thing is that because PLEC2G10 was secreted, we were afraid
that we may not be able to target, but you can see these are three independent
tumors from different patients, and we can find PLEC2G10 retained in the
tumor microenvironment up to day five.
So now we're blocking
PLEC2G10 and try to see if we can redirect and block
the T cell exclusion. And this, I think, is a really reasonable
way to do development of this type of compounds in the
future
that we hope will support one day patient therapeutics.
So in conclusion, from this second part, I hope I convinced you again that
immune cancer cell spatial interactions are relevant for adaptive immune
rejection, and in particular, T cell exclusion,
it's frequent in about 20% or so of
lung cancers, and it's associated with immune evasion and IO resistance.
And I think what we're seeing is that spatial exclusion amounts to a
new way of T cell dysfunction because it's just enough to
block tumor rejection.
I also hope I convinced you that targeting T cell excluders has prominent clinical
potential, and we're now figuring out the biology and trying to
partner with companies that would be interested in targeting this type of
molecules.
And finally, I think we created a model, this primary explants that allow
preclinical testing and hopefully will support the development of these
molecules in the future.So with that, I end.
This is a work of many, many people over many years.
These are my lab members. These are collaborators at Yale
and a number of external collaborators. I will not go through this because of time.
A lot of funding sources, and particularly NIH, which we certainly
need to have long-term projects
more than ever.
And this is a picture of my lab. I will, again, not describe,
but I think I have the best lab in the world for a number of reasons.
I
show data from many, many people, mostly from Kishor Ranjan,
who is here working on the TAP project.
Boyu is working on T cell exclusion.
Javi, antigen presentation immunoposome.
And then Miguel, who is sitting in the room,
and is here and has done a lot of the work on immune exclusion.
And with that, I end, and I will be happy to take questions. Thank you.
Kurt, wonderful talk. Thanks. Mike Saracci.
I wanted to ask you to describe the phenomenon
beautifully, and you have a tendency to have
thought about most of the questions that enter my head already.
So my question is,
for the TAP2 loss, you showed how it can be detected
and addressed, but
as we think about patients coming onto therapy,
I'm thinking about circulating biomarkers or ways to determine
or predict which patients are likely to benefit
from that or undergo that process.
And I don't think I understand completely the mechanism preceding that that leads
to the epigenetic suppression. So again, I'm sure you've
thought about this, about the utility and the practicality of
prediction before the patient goes on therapy.
Yeah, it's a great question. So
the short answer is that measuring IL-4, which
is the main mechanism behind TAP2 loss, is a very
viable, reasonable way to do sort of blood, like liquid biopsy type
of the testing. We still don't fully know if it
correlates exactly with the loss of TAP2 in the tumor microenvironment
production, but that's certainly an avenue to do that.
Now, the thing, though, is that the cancer cell-specific nature of
the phenomenon prevents doing sort of
bulk type of assay. When we look at RNA-seq, the contribution of
transcript from the stromal cells is sufficient to mask the cancer-selected
downregulation. So I think the best hope is IL-4 in plasma, which is
measurable. We do that all the time, and I think it has the likelihood to
identify the patients in which this biology is dominant and may benefit from
treatment.
Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. Thank you.
I have two questions. One is about
TAP2. When you do the screening to see which
compounds
aggregate TAP2, I see that a lot of compounds shown as a
hit were actually antitumor,
showing antitumor effects, as you said, some of them are already approved.
So I wonder if the compounds, when they
induce TAP2 expression, do they
start killing the cells, or this is sub-lethal concentration?
Yeah. So the short answer is we don't know.
When we screen, we generally add 10 micromolar flat, because we cannot
test every concentration and for every time.
But we did some experiments with the dose dependency, and the
EC50 varies a little bit between cells, so there is some component of
toxicity. But certainly, we can achieve restoration of TAP2
without the EC50
for killing. So there is a little bit of a disconnect and an opportunity to
basically achieve some of the immunostimulatory effect before
the cytotoxic effect, or at least the EC50.
I see. Thanks. And the other question was about the
spatial data when you show the
CD4 T cells and the B cells are aggregated outside the
tumor bed. Did you see that those
CD8 T cells are actively cytotoxic, meaning
granzyme B or perforin, they're already expressed, or they're
somehow more a
little immature?
Yeah. So
I don't think we can interpret that very well.
The complexity of this is like another part of my lab works a lot on
T cells. And what we have learned, I think the hard way,
particularly in human tumors, is that the markers we generally considered
as markers of activation, like granzyme B and K67, are
actually enriching dysfunctional cells.
And I think there is this idea now that high granzyme K, low granzyme B,
but I think the most important thing is that I don't think we can interpret that
data very well. That's why, at this point, I only rely on functional.
If I see them killing,
I call them active antitumor. If they don't kill, I don't call them.
But PD-1, LAG-3, TIM-3, granzyme B, even
the sort of relatively newer markers, TCF7,
and Tox, I don't think we can interpret that very well.
So I can't answer honestly what the phenotype is, but I can tell you that
when we restore TAP2, the T cells kill more.
So I think they at least have the potential to be tumor
antigen-specific and cytotoxic in nature.
So it's a humble answer, but it's the best I can give you now.
Yeah. Thank you. I really like that you have a multi
aspect to tackle the question. So thanks so much for the
talk.
Thank you.
Okay, if there are no more questions, I think we can close here, and I hope you
have a great evening and rest of the meeting. Thank you very much for coming.